[Musica]
ciao a tutti vorrei parlare con voi di
cose di cui non parliamo mai e vorrei
far partire da voi facendo di qualche
domanda per tastare il terreno non siete
obbligati ad alzare la mano per
rispondere ma pensa te dentro di voi la
risposta avete mai avete mai parlato con
la vostra famiglia con i vostri amici di
politica di coltura di diritti civili
immagino di si vedono molti si è un tema
molto interessante molto diffuso e
soprattutto per chi è appassionato è
sicuramente un tema di discussione
quanti di voi invece hanno o direbbero
al proprio amico che vanno dallo
psicologo andassero dallo psicologo
forse un po di meno rispetto a prima ma
sicuramente un tema che è stato molto
sdoganato nell'ultimo periodo anche se
non ancora del tutto
infine quanti di voi hanno mai parlato
con i loro amici più stretti di orgasmi
gli orgasmi che non hanno mai avuto
vedo di risposte affermative pensavo
molte di meno perfetto in ogni caso
sicuramente un tema di cui si discute di
meno su cui c'è sicuramente più tabù e
sono sicura che tra di voi ci sono un
sacco di persone molto estroverse che
non hanno problemi a condividere le loro
passioni dolori i loro ideali per quanto
magari un po pi un po più delicati di
altri quelle altre persone però sono
anche sicura che molti di voi come me si
sono trovati in quella situazione in un
gruppo in cui si sta discutendo
animatamente di un tema dove la nostra
opinione è diversa da quella che la
maggioranza sta prendendo e dove quindi
la nostra opinione
viene silenziata non ce la sentiamo di
esporre sempre le nostre idee di fronte
una maggioranza che ha una chiara un
chiaro orientamento
questa situazione è perfettamente
normale e c'è pure stata costruita una
teoria sociologica al riguardo che è
quella di noel noi manca una sociologa
che negli anni 70 ha identificato questo
meccanismo sociale come la spirale del
silenzio quindi quella sensazione
dell'individuo che quando ha una
opinione diversa da quella che ritiene
essere la maggioranza porta al silenzio
quindi la persona che effettivamente
percepisce la propria opinione
come contrario molto lontana da quella
della maggioranza non se la sente non è
incentivato a esprimere liberamente la
propria opinione questo la sociologa lo
applicava alla pressione del dei mass
media sulla opinione pubblica dominante
però come potete capire benissimo voi
possiamo applicarlo a una serie di sfere
della nostra vita delle più disparate
tutte delle sfere dove però è presente
in piccolo commedia portata una
componente di diversità di tabù
pensiamo ha opinioni diverse ha idee
diverse situazioni diverse a sensazioni
diverse queste sensazioni diverse
ci portano molto spesso appunto a tacere
riguarda la nostra situazione e può
portare a livello culturale
effettivamente a cambiare l'opinione
pubblica ed avere delle serie
ripercussioni anche sulla propria
esperienza sulle cose tangibili che ci
succedono nella vita e
prendiamo per esempio l'intimità come
esempio l'intimità per definizione è
intima ed è giusto che possa essere così
però dov'è il confine tra quello che io
voglio sia intimo quindi quello che io
voglio condividere con una persona dove
voglio quando voglio e con chi voglio e
dove invece l'intimità diventa un
qualcosa che io dovrei tenere intima
secondo la società in cui viviamo quindi
qual è la differenza qual è il confine
tra quello che devo dire dovrei dire è
quello che voglio dire è per spiegarvi
meglio questa questa differenza questa
confine vorrei raccontarvi una storia
che la mia storia quando avevo 16 anni
tutti i miei amici iniziavano conoscere
il proprio corpo a conoscere le
sensazioni del proprio corpo ad avere
rapporti sessuali
io da subito mi resi conto che c'era un
problema io non riuscivo a fare sesso in
nessun modo anche non importava quanto
lubrificante utilizzassi quanto volessi
bene alla persona che avevo di fronte
quante candeline illuminate si fossero
nella stanza non c'era verso e quindi un
certo punto mi chiedevo ma è veramente
questo eccesso è veramente questo quello
di cui tutti parlano che tutti cercano
con così disperata passione amore e
voglia perché se a questo io non lo
voglio
che ogni volta che provavo oltre anno
riuscirci sentivo un dolore lancinante
che era fuori dall immaginabile
allora passò un anno passare 12 anni
passarono tre anni iniziali l'università
inizia a girare il mondo con un sacco di
persone nuove da tutto il mondo ma
ancora nulla non riusciva a sbloccare
questo problema e ovviamente in tutti
quegli anni ho cercato attivamente una
soluzione ho fatto migliaia di ricerca
sul web ma senza trovare una singola
risorsa che potesse effettivamente dare
una risposta a quello che chiedevo senza
trovare una symbola testimonianza su
alcun forum che mi dimostrasse che altre
persone nel mondo stavano sentendo
quello che sentivo io e questa cosa nel
tempo mi porta chiaramente a farmi delle
domande più serie cioè c'è qualcosa di
sbagliato in è un segno
dovrei obbligarmi a fare a farmi del
male
è così che fanno le persone si obbligano
farsi del male per poi superare il
dolore ovviamente non era questo il caso
tra gli in quel momento mi sentivo
assolutamente sola mi sentivo sbagliata
e mi sentivo diversa e quindi ovviamente
altre cose che ho fatto è stato cercare
risposta e nelle amicizie ho cercato di
chiedere i miei amici se provassero lo
stesso ma non era così nessuno sapeva
effettivamente mettersi nei miei panni e
capire cosa intendessi e quindi non
sapevano aiutarmi chiaramente ovviamente
mi fece visitare da decine e decine di
ginecologi in tutta italia ma la
risposta era sempre la stessa tu non hai
niente se a nato anatomicamente perfetta
quindi basta che ti rilassi e vedrai che
riuscirai non è stato così mi sono
rilassata ve lo posso garantire
ma a un certo punto questa assenza di
risposte mi ha portato a spegnermi
completamente non ho più cercato niente
non ho più fatto domande non ho parlato
di questa cosa quegli amici sono
arrivata al punto di non pensare più di
avere questo problema quando questo
problema c'era ed eccola qui di nuovo la
spirale del silenzio
se nessuno intorno a te parla di un tema
tu non ne parli e se non ne parli non
troverai mai una soluzione perché non
c'è nessuno che ha risposto o può
aiutarti quello che è successo è che
dopo otto anni
da quando ha iniziato a ricercare una
soluzione ho incontrato una ginecologa
che era molto informato al riguardo
e mi ha finalmente detto cosa avevo si
chiama vaginismo è un'ipertensione
muscolare il vaginismo è l'impossibilità
alla penetrazione che questo sia durante
un rapporto sessuale
l'inserimento di un assorbente interno
la visita ginecologica e con lei scoprì
che tantissime ragazze della mia età e
anche più grandi soffrivano di questa
cosa ma la cosa più bella la notizia più
buona e perché si poteva curare e anche
in tempi molto brevi infatti solo 4 mesi
con la terapia che mi ha prescritto
questa ginecologa sono riuscita a
superare facilmente questa la fase acuta
diciamo della disfunzione che avevo ea
fare cose che fino a pochissimo tempo
prima non mi sarei mai immaginato di
poter fare otto anni per dare un nome a
quello che sentivo ho cercato di dare un
modo in modo disperato e solamente
quattro mesi per risolverlo è la cosa
più assurda sapete qual è chi non è un
caso raro il mio ci sono migliaia di
donne e di uomini che soffrono di quelle
che vengono chiamate le disfunzioni al
pavimento pelvico quindi questo muscolo
questa fascia insieme di muscoli che
abbiamo tutti gli uomini e donne
all'altezza del bacino che può diventare
può mai funzionare poi diventare troppo
teso troppo rilassato e quindi può
portare a queste disfunzioni che vedete
alcune le conoscerete sicuramente
l'avete sentito parlare cistite
candidosi altri un po meno conosciute
come la vulvodinia il vaginismo per
l'appunto con la dismenorrea che è il
dolore durante il ciclo mestruale di
queste disfunzioni indovinate quante
persone ne soffrono
prendiamo le donne per esempio quante e
quante donne al mondo soffrono di questa
cosa
una donna su quattro
nella sua vita soffre almeno di una di
queste disfunzioni questo significa che
in questa sala qui adesso ci sono almeno
altre otto nove ragazze oltre a me a
soffrire di questa cosa è la cosa più
assurda non è questa la cosa più assurda
che ci mettono dai 5 ai 10 anni per
trovare una risposta alle loro domande
non per guarire per dare una risposta
per trovare una diagnosi e voi vi
chiederete come è possibile che nel 2021
ci si metta così tanto tempo per trovare
una risposta a un tema così diffuso le
risposte sono tante ovviamente è una
risposta complessa ci sono tanti
elementi che si intrecciano ma la
principale la prima e single ha ragione
è il tabù sociale presente nella nostra
cultura che impedisce alle persone di
parlare a voce alta di questo problema e
quindi di trovare attivamente una
soluzione questo tabù ha delle radici
profondamente radicate nella cultura in
cui viviamo pensate per esempio alla
normalizzazione del dolore quante volte
uomini e donne abbiamo sentito parlare
abbiamo seguito la frase è normale
provare dolore durante un rapporto
sessuale soprattutto le prime volte non
è vero quante volte abbiamo sentito dire
è normale provare dolore durante il
ciclo mestruale
non è vero
e pensavo poi all'educazione sessuale e
affettiva di conoscenza del nostro corpo
ripeto per uomini e per donne che
abbiamo ricevuto durante il nostro
percorso educativo quasi completamente
assente eccetto per i più fortunati e
questo ci porta a non conoscere il
nostro corpo a non ascoltare i segnali
che ci manda quando ci sono dei problemi
ea reagire a questi problemi per questo
motivo qualche mese fa ho lanciato una
community on line che vuole fare
esattamente questo vuole minimizzare i
tempi diagnostici di chi soffre di
disfunzione al pavimento pelvico
cercando di partire
dall'abbattimento dei tabù
il progetto si chiama che il è
essenzialmente vuole essere un luogo
dove non è normale stare male e dove le
persone che soffrono di queste
disfunzioni possono essere accompagnate
dalla a alla z nella piena
consapevolezza del loro corpo per capire
cosa è sbagliato cosa non è sbagliato
cosa normale così ma non è normale e
quali sono soprattutto gli strumenti
concreti per risolvere il proprio
problema in questi ultimi mesi abbiamo
parlato con tantissime persone con
centinaia di uomini donne che ci hanno
stipendiato ogni giorno e grazie a loro
abbiamo
raccolto diciamo tre consigli tre
caratteristiche che riguardano il tabù
che mi sento di consigliare di
condividere con voi perché sono tre
elementi che penso siano abbastanza
trasversale a tutti i tabù e soprattutto
sono tre elementi che noi oggi possiamo
implementare dal singolo secondo in cui
usciremo da questa sala le tre cose che
abbiamo imparato sono le seguenti primo
ci si fida di chi ha vissuto
l'esperienza nel momento in cui abbiamo
aperto i nostri canali
abbiamo rilasciato le prime interviste
sia letteralmente riversata un'enormità
di gente le chat che ti ha condiviso
senza nessun tipo di imbarazzo la
propria esperienza nel momento in cui ti
trovi davanti a una persona che ha
passato esattamente la tua esperienza in
cui ha sofferto cometa in determinati
momenti in cui sa cosa provi sa quali
sono le tue paure non avrai un singolo
secondo in cui aspetterei prima di
condividere la tua esperienza con questa
persona perché ti fidi di lei
essenzialmente tutti i giorni ci
arrivano messaggi come questi in cui le
persone parlano con sconosciuti perché
questo siamo per loro condividendo i
loro dettagli più intimi nel modo più
spontaneo possibile una cosa che non ci
aspettavamo in questi termini la seconda
cosa è che un tono voice fresco toglie
l'imbarazzo quindi un linguaggio chiaro
dritto a chi legge anche divertente a
tratti sicuramente può aiutare non solo
a togliere l'imbarazzo è anche a
sdrammatizzare delle situazioni che sono
sicuramente un po pesanti ma anche ad
avvicinare tutte quelle persone che
prima di questo momento non hanno mai
toccato con mano questi temi che non si
sono non hanno mai osato avvicinarsi
troppo questi temi quindi quello che
facciamo con l usare questo linguaggio
per veicolare qualsiasi tipo di
informazione
dai dati statistici alle informazioni
scientifiche dei paper scientifici a
qualsiasi tipo di testimonianza che ci
arriva e funziona terzo il consiglio più
forse banale e scontato ma assolutamente
il più importante è che basta parlarne
basta veramente pochissimo per abbattere
un tabù e plasmare la cultura in cui
viviamo basta iniziare a parlarne
aprirsi rivelare alla persona che
abbiamo davanti la nostra paura più
grande è il nostro imbarazzo più grande
e questa persona si aprirà con da farà
lo stesso lo farà cascata si genererà un
effetto è un circolo virtuoso che
porterà effettivamente a plasmare la
società e la cultura
penso che tutti noi abbiamo qualcosa di
cui abbiamo paura di cui abbiamo
imbarazzo di che non ci fa stare bene è
l'unica singola cosa con cui possiamo
iniziare ad affrontare questa cosa è
effettivamente
parlarne e possiamo iniziare a farlo qui
e adesso grazie mille
[Applauso]